it is time to raise your glass and
celebrate cinco de mayo with some great
craft brews kevin lingley the director
of marketing and pr at able baker is
here to introduce us to some recipes to
spice up our cervezas welcome thank you
well first of all tell us a little bit
about the nevada craft brewers
association that you're a part of sure
so the nevada craft brewers association
is basically a collective uh
group of breweries that are local to
nevada up in reno and vegas you can see
a lot of them displayed here you know
they're all small uh family owned
breweries they're not big corporations
and so you know it's great to support
the smaller uh you know family-owned
businesses we love supporting local and
who knew that so many of these delicious
beers
were made right here in northern and
southern nevada this is impressive so
cinco de mayo what what do we have on
tap i'm seeing a lot of options yeah we
have several stuff so
you know
we have a mexican lager that that could
be you know bready and sweet and that's
usually a base of a lot of beers you'll
see a lot of them they'll add uh
chili peppers to it you know jalapenos
serrano ancho chilis
we have it from grape basin they've won
three uh great
great american fest gold medals and then
we have um love lady has hatch chili and
then you know we have some other ones
that have fruit purees and chilies to it
so sweet and spicy it's like kind of
hearty it sounds like all right well
let's let's do a little taste test what
do we have here let's can we try this
yeah so that's the el paso loco that we
make that's that's a standard mexican
lager it's kind of bready a little bit
sweet
not too hoppy not too hoppy it does have
a nice balance to it
it's like refreshing i do like this one
a lot yeah i like when you use words
like bready and hoppy
that's a vertically described stuff i
love that so this is good to pair with
what like some tacos yeah i mean
anything with heat that'll that'll tame
it down yeah
it's nice when you have something that's
super spicy and then that'll be a nice
balance for it okay what if we want
something a little sweeter yeah so then
we have our chata it's a mexican style
horchata inspired ale a cream ale
so you have cinnamon vanilla and lactose
in it oh cheers got cheers to you
and then we uh you're gonna ask about
the rim yeah i'm gonna say what's up so
we rim the glass with cajeta which is
like a caramelized goat milk and then a
sugar cinnamon uh blend and it just kind
of brings out that cinnamon oh my gosh
that's so good i'm choking on it it's
delicious this is like a dessert it is
it's great oh my gosh okay
stop do not get rid of this i'm saying
this save that one that is amazing wow
so where can we get these craft brews so
you can go to any of the tap rooms um or
breweries here in town or up in reno
you can find a lot of them on draft
around town that carry local craft beers
you know at abel baker we have both of
these in cans right now
and
we're doing on cinco de mayo we're
actually doing a rum barrel aged version
of our chata that we're releasing um
we're doing a pond dolce
pairing with cerveza which is a tap room
around the corner on uh tomorrow night
actually and huddle will be there as
well and so you can try some different
stuff pair with some sweet breads there
it's gonna be a great event salute
everyone this is fantastic thank you for
joining us this is amazing we'll be
right back